[Music]
in Disney rant news you know super
excited for this one uh submitted by my
name is Barry Allen what's up E mom's
rant about the childless Millennials at
Disney World goes viral Oh
childless Millennials mm-hmm we've all
seen them yeah like like kids like a 19
year old 21 year olds might be a part of
like 30 year old people yeah don't
that's going without a child like all
the [ __ ] from the Playboy Mansion and
go up there and I'm like what are you
[ __ ] doing this is weird
the mid-20 it is it that weird when you
see like a bunch of girls you know it's
like you always see that [ __ ] squad
they're on the same teachers and it's
like it's like Casey hands like
Bachelorette and like with Mickey Mouse
why do you wanna go to Disney World for
your bachelor is not from LA so they
can't go like everyday so for them it's
like an event order I hate I agree why
do you hate Disney well no I love this
way from where you originally from
Georgia that's why are from Southern
California yeah it's so interesting
they just feel like wherever there's a
Disney and people aren't from it cuz
they're like there's one in Orlando but
people that don't live near there and
having gone there throughout their
childhood they don't understand me I
know Californians absolutely love Disney
but it's just like you're selling a
false dream like where's the fairy tale
of the girl who saves her [ __ ] self
she is her own white knight story it
needs to be one that's not what Disney
Disneyland at least is showing you it's
just a fantasy world I'd go over for the
cheese pretzels but have you seen the
chat like okay you have a child have you
seen the other parents there yeah I have
photos of them sleeping yeah
and in line standing up okay like and
kids are harassing how many people love
Disneyland
that's so Pat why my not what this moms
rant is all about so it looks like this
they post it on Facebook and she's mad
Pizza that pisses me off to no end when
I see childless couples without at
Disneyworld - it's an angry red faces
for DW yeah
our Disneyworld is a family amusement
park yet these immature Millennials
throw away their money on useless crap
they have no idea the joy and happy
happiness it is to mothers who buy their
babies treats and toys they will never
experience the exhaustion that it is to
chase a three-year-old around it and
getting stared at assuming I'm a bad
mother this [ __ ] in some very [ __ ]
shorts was buying a Mickey pretzel and
Aiden wanted one but the line was very
long so I said later and it broke his
poor little heart and he cried I wanted
to [ __ ] pretzel from that trip like
thanks [ __ ] you made my son cry more
angry faces
she made her son cry they were also
around written people without children
need to be banned mothers with children
should be allowed to skip all the line
yes you had no idea what it is like to
stand in line for three hours with a
cranky tired exhausted toddler and I
can't just tell them that we can't do
something because it's his vacation - I
hate childless women with a burning
passion she should've had kids she yeah
oh she's [ __ ] wishing she was the
[ __ ] happy what it is she wasn't a [ __ ]
mother that kid wouldn't be cranky order
yeah my kid I'm a [ __ ] mother and my
kids he's cranky and tired I'm like okay
this isn't about me I shouldn't be in
mind cuz my toddler doesn't know what
the [ __ ] happened it's her fault that
she's eating a [ __ ] pretzel it could
have been anybody eating a [ __ ]
pretzel and the kids like mommy I want
that I just want to go out on a limb
here and say I have been kicked out of
like a Disney theme park where with fire
yeah only and it wasn't really my fault
was just because they might get makeup
artists was twerking and lying the whole
time
and you wouldn't stop keep all of you
out Oh I mean working is not something
you want to do at Disneyland did they
ask him to please stop working first oh
okay he just couldn't stop he just could
it's a song was stuck in his head why
did you kick - because I was associated
with the twerking wait for the legs I
should have I picture him with his whole
makeup can on his hip and oh yeah oh he
was he was like wow yeah so everyone was
like everyone was responding to this
because someone took this from Facebook
and tweet it out with the caption this
is my new favorite wild mommy post it's
me the millennial [ __ ] who just goes to
Disney World to make children cry yes I
mean a lot of people were like what the
[ __ ] so this this whole controversy here
was like split because a lot of people
are saying yeah it's [ __ ] weird why
do adults go without kids to Disney
that's a good place to go on the date a
lot of people like going there because
theme parks everybody go to theme parks
because Disney people are [ __ ] weird
yeah that's what happened the other half
are saying
Orlin and then yeah so the other half
are saying like you know what like why
why can't I be there like it's part of
my childhood too like what the [ __ ] like
I can enjoy it too I'm paying a lot of
money I should be able to enjoy this too
and then the other part is people saying
well she kind of does have a point you
know like this really is for kids and
you know if you're if you don't have a
kid then maybe you shouldn't be going
there but yelling at adults for eating
ice cream ice cream for kids why the
[ __ ] are you in baskin-robbins you're
like a carnival yeah you go on and you
go yeah you go take a date there to the
fair or whatever what's I don't know
what's difference I'll get it ya know if
you could spend if you spent eight hours
in the Baskin Robbins because you want
to get the nostalgic feeling of how you
felt when your kid in a baskin-robbins
and I'd say you're pretty weird but just
going to Baskin Robbins it's like 100
acres big you got you see myself I could
be in the freight office hi I try to do
yeah I got I liked her idea though of
like if you have a kid and sound like a
skip the line thing no
[ __ ] way that's stupidest spot yeah
that is stupid why that's why everybody
dude that's why you want it that's like
people who who every day have somebody
to ride to work with like I love the
carpool lane it's awesome I'm like [ __ ]
you yeah this would be the kids have to
be like in a certain age aid age range
that they can actually enjoy the ride
that they're gonna get on and then not
be like you know the cranky three year
old just disrupt disrupting the entire
line look first of all those
three-year-olds hit you right in the
crotch cuz of how tall they are and its
really [ __ ] noisy and we wanna get
away from my pudding I'm gonna rent a
kid from a friend of mine and go to the
front of every [ __ ] why if you have
to carry a toddler with you around what
about people then that go alright once
your kids not even gonna know what the
[ __ ] is going on then we can't allow
these kids cuz now it's like wasting it
you don't I mean like there's so many
different arguments that could happen so
it's like who the [ __ ] are you to say
you can do this or do not know or not do
this like that's just not here with the
really old guys like is that your kid or
your you know you think it's not my it's
not my fault you got a [ __ ] kid it's
not my fault I'm just trying to eat a
pretzel I could see where she's coming
from but skipping the line see it Bob
well what do you see that where she's
coming from
like what points so the fact that like
let's say she wanted to get that pretzel
for her kid right yeah then she doesn't
want to wait or like the kid is already
cranky whatever the weather is like you
know to wait in that long ass line from
a whole bunch of adults when you're at a
kid's park
I get the frustration cuz you're like
that's supposed to be for us and you're
clogging up the line that's how you feel
or not yeah I mean not that I feel like
that I feel that way yeah I don't get it
so do you feel like if you're at a gym
and there's a line for the bench the
buff people should come from the line of
the fat people you're saying like these
buff guys the gyms made for buff people
fit you guys need a weight cuz it wasn't
made for that yeah I know I think the
gyms made for fat people so the buff
people shuttle yeah is it you already
buff get out of here
there's a buff guy making that argument
I could be like I I see how you can see
that not that I agree with it see how he
could come to that conclusion that's how
I feel about her if you're a monster
- that's awesome
if you're going to a theme park why are
you getting mad that there's gonna be
[ __ ] line
you're going to a theme park and who's
in the line it doesn't matter yet
there's a line yeah you gotta expect
lines together there you're going to a
theme park for lives you spend more time
in lines than that yeah like you're
signing up for it you know I think what
it does though is she makes it their
fault like cuz cuz yeah it's like your
fault that my kid is giving me problems
yeah yes
cuz the kid is bitching about I want to
[ __ ] eat a pretzel mommy and she's
like I don't want to wait in line you
could have waited in line and gave him a
damn pretzel you didn't want to wait
well--there's you're impatient you're
[ __ ] also at the different solution to
make the kid happy another way no she's
like because she's stressed out she
wants to point the finger you [ __ ]
millennial well there's this
sanctimonious like I'm a mom badge that
people do all the time that's like it's
like I have a kid so excuse me like my
kid is like need something right now so
excuse me right now but I need to do
this right now
I [ __ ] hate people put their problems
on other people it's like no that's your
[ __ ] problem like a [ __ ] problem
one that's dressed down guess what [ __ ]
saw a lot of women with a lot of babies
you're not the only [ __ ] wife yeah
it's not that hard to have a baby
because it wasn't your fault that they
had a kid yeah and you're not that
special because there's a lot of women
with kids yep it's not just you said I
think that you should do the princess
Disney princess movie about a princess
who's a single mom thank you no no but I
want you to do it so then I want you to
do it so that I could fall asleep
watching it yeah it's really a really
nice story you know
the last sentence was the one that
really irked me too cuz I'm like what
was it again it says I [ __ ] hate
childless women with a burning passion
[ __ ] whole thing about just childless
people geez just really she hates her
life she wishes she was single she
wished she never had kids
no she's [ __ ] jealous of the freedom
that they that she sees that let me get
short shorts and look good I have to do
[ __ ] running after my three-year-old
that's probably cause she's fat as [ __ ]
and can't breathe yep and for all she
knows this chicks a virgin in short
shorts give me an athlete maybe issued
this looks really [ __ ] I got trade
like that when I was married all the
time and I was like [ __ ] I'm
married like leave me alone I want you
but just cuz I was wearing shorts people
that was a house why why do it is it
mainly like ladies that get angry at you
or guys everybody everyone thinks I've
been such an easy life but maybe you
know women are angry cuz they're
projecting that they can wear the shorts
and then men are angry at her because
they can't get I like short shorts all
the time um and I wish a video on video
I do for fun
were you wearing sparkly short [ __ ] I
should have been okay damn it it's not
the trick well that's that's the whole
that's the whole 100 that's why here I
like short shorts on guys and girls
because for guys it's funny I never
girls it's sexy you know it's so funny I
just saw some seriously short shorts on
guys at this gym I went to because those
were my chiropractors and I was like
holy [ __ ] those are shorter than mine
and they're tighter yes like the
cheerleading ones remember the ones that
you rolled up oh yeah maybe they're gay
yeah they were but I was like hey I need
that in my I need to look like oh wait
guys where they look like kids so it's
always funny to me and it with girls
where it makes me horny
[Laughter]
[Music]